there's a great non-profit in town
that's providing essential services
to at-risk babies and in connection with
that
is findlay toyota findlay automotive i
should say
and we're talking about uh tyler good to
have you with us
the lullaby connection how are you doing
i'm doing wonderful how are you
good tell us about lullaby connection
and what you guys are doing with them
well so first of all you know we do a
lot with a lot of different charities in
town so it's always kind of exciting to
find one that we haven't been involved
with before and that's doing great stuff
and so just recently we learned about
the lullaby connection which is
they've actually been in operation here
for like 18 or 19 years
and they're just down the street from
our headquarters but uh
what we found out is that they serve a
real important need in town which is
that there's a lot of
parents brand new parents that have a
newborn child
but for whatever reason the pandemic or
just economic circumstances they don't
have the resources
to properly take care of their newborn
infant and that's where the lullaby
connection
uh gets involved and what they do is
you know their mission is to make sure
that every every newborn child has
uh has something to start their life
with something new
something warm something that's uh
filled with love and so they try to
provide those types of items
to these parents to give to their
newborn children such a great program
and i was uh i hadn't heard of them
either which is amazing
because they've been around for a couple
of decades yes
yeah so what they do is they provide uh
what they call a layout
package and i i had to look that term up
but what a lay it
is is a set of clothing and accessories
for a newborn child and so the lullaby
connection provides these and with
blankets pajamas diapers and other
essential items
for newborn babies and they've provided
more than 50 000 of these layouts over
the last
50 or 20 years or so and so that's
really cool but what how we became aware
of them was just recently
we learned about their holiday need and
they normally serve about 100
families a year this year they're trying
to serve 600 and we learned that they
were way short of the items they needed
to help these families
in this very unusual year so we sent a
couple of our
our people chad and kristen from here at
our headquarters and sent them to the
store
and we delivered a whole vehicle full
of toys and items to help them and so
they're meeting the needs of those 600
families
for the holidays which is something that
makes us feel good
based on everything that's going on
right now well you guys do so much for
so many non-profits and so many people
in this community and we thank you for
it
um the viewers people watching right now
if they want to help some of these
children they can help as well right
yeah so obviously uh financial support
is something that they could always use
but they also
accept donations of new toys and clothes
for infants
uh even baby books and that sort of
thing and so you can always
provide that sort of thing the best way
to get more information is go to
lullabyconnection.org learn about what
they do
how you can help and get involved and we
really encourage it if you're going to
support something here at the holidays
this year
we'd love to have you support the
lullaby connection it is a great cause
tyler at as always you done good
thanks so much great to see you thank
you so much and we do want to thank
findlay automotive for being one of our
community
pride partners las vegas now we'll be
right back